police in Harare block major roads as
Zimbabwe begins a 21 day nationwide
lockdown if people can't prove why is
essential for them to travel to the city
center they are told to go back home so
I think maybe those measures been taking
place but the current any limitation
movement is something to do that
the spread of the corona virus other
countries have also put in place similar
measures in varying degrees but
Zimbabweans living with hyper inflation
and high unemployment worried that
closing down markets and non-essential
businesses will mean less cash for
millions already struggling I don't
think that treatment is going to be
giving a one-week seem to be too hard
for us on day one of the lockdown Harari
streets were largely deserted health
officials say they are ready to minimize
the impact of the outbreak should there
be more infections when our only
transport operators for the state are
allowed to work they are needed for
people who are in essential services the
government has also closed borders and
banned large gatherings pharmacies fuel
stations and supermarkets can stay open
during the three-week lockdown but daily
water fuel and food shortages means
queuing for hours looking for basic
commodities practicing coronavirus
prevention methods such as social
distancing is nearly impossible for many
it's a dilemma between heading out to
provide for their family or staying at
home her Matassa al jazeera hari